on a confié le mandat particulier et à
hydro québec et à énergies afin de
travailler ensemble pour faire en sorte
qu'en 2030 les émissions à l'égard de
nos bâtiments diminue de 50 %
hydro-québec affirme être au coeur de la
mise en oeuvre du plan pour une économie
verte présentée par le ministre de
l'environnement benoît charette hier
avec nous ce soir ce film rochus pdg
d'hydro-québec pour ce format d'un
brushing
bonsoir monsieur fillion quel effet aura
ce plan qui a été annoncé hier sur vos
activités sur votre chiffre d'affaires
pour les dix prochaines années
mais voyez vous on raisonne pas
tellement pour nous que pour notre
chiffre d'affaires pour tout vous dire
monsieur fillion
évidemment ils brilleront une
consommation accrue d'électricité
ça va contribuer à notre chiffre
d'affaires mais pour tout vous dire
notre posture mentale aujourd'hui c'est
de contribuer à la fois à la transition
énergétique et d'y contribuer de manière
pragmatique donc ambitions pragmatisme
et ici ce qu'on cherche à faire c'est
d'aider tous nos concitoyens tous nos
clients que nous consommateurs tous les
québécois et les québécoises a rencontré
leurs ambitions environnementales mais
aussi à le faire de manière sensée pour
ne pas que ça coûte très cher toute
cette transition énergétique
alors notre objectif ici c'est pas
d'augmenter notre chiffre d'affaires
vraiment qu'ils savent est une
conséquence mais notre objectif ici
c'est de le faire de la manière la plus
pragmatique pour noter que à passa à
l'auto électrique largement on veut
passer en veut qui est de plus en plus
de tout électrique au cours des cinq dix
quinze prochaines années
vous voulez aussi augmenté quand même
vos exportations ça fait partie aussi du
plein est ce que vous prévoyez qu'il
faudra créer de nouvelles capacités de
production au québec en fait
présentement on à l'énergie qu'il faut
pour servir à la fois l'augmentation de
la demande au québec est à la fois nos
projets d'exportation
tout se vaut concourir et à la réduction
des gaz à effet de serre de notre coin
du monde mais aussi
à notre bien-être économique une fois
qu'on dit ça il faut comprendre par
ailleurs au québec on chauffe eau
chauffent à l'électricité et pendant
quelques heures
pendant quelques jours l'hiver quand il
fait très froid et que tout le monde
sauf en même temps en arrivant à la
maison puis qu'on parle de sécheuse mais
qu'on adapte et libre concorde la
vaisselle lors on escompte en appel
en période de pointe et le boulot
d'hydro-québec avec tous vos hôtes avec
tous les citoyens du québec ça va être
de travailler tous ensemble à réduire
notre consommation par an cette pointe
alors on veut prendre le plus de charges
possibles électrique dans ce qu'on
appelle dans la base dans la journée ben
dans la très très grande majorité du
temps mais ces quelques journées lancé
quelques heures où il fait vraiment très
froid faut qu'on travaille ensemble à
réduire la consommation d'électricité
donc on va pas se créer des capacités de
production supplémentaires parce qu'on
va avoir plus d'automobiles de bornes
électriques par exemple ou parce qu'on
veut exporter davantage ce que vous
voulez faire c'est de l' avantage de
miser sur l'économie et sur l'efficacité
énergétique
oui économie efficacité énergétique
en fait il aussi complémentarité alors
vous parliez d'entrée de jeu le y avait
le magic l'énergie et la main dessus et
avec avec la collaboration là moi je
veux attirer l'attention des
téléspectateurs ce soir sur un avantage
est qu on parie pour le québec un
avantage extraordinaire qu'on retrouve
très peu travers le monde le fait que
chez nous il ya deux grands
propriétaires et deux grands opérateurs
des deux grands réseaux électriques
hegarty ailleurs dans l'angle s'il
fallait mettre autour d'une table et les
distributeurs électriques et d asie dans
un seul pays ne vous pourriez avoir 15
16 17 personnes qui auraient des
intérêts commerciaux
parce qu'ils sont il serait détenu à la
bouche p.diddy ça serait de s'arracher
des parts de marché or au québec on a on
y peut on est des gens tous dédiés
qu'on soit chez nrj où hydro-québec à
cette transition énergétique l'appui
vous faire en sorte que oui réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre mais
le faire au moindre coût possible alors
travailler ensemble plateau je vous
parlais de la pointe merry
en travaillant ensemble ce qu'on va
faire c'est qu'on va prendre des charges
qui aujourd'hui des charges de chauffage
aujourd'hui qui sont servis à gaz
naturel on va les prendre à
l'électricité mais en période de pointe
dont je vous parlais tantôt on va
prendre
charge de la chauve qui on va la mettre
à gaz naturel donc on va baisser la
consommation absolue de gaz naturel on
va augmenter la consommation absolue
d'électricité on va réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre mon
vol faire au meilleur prix possible et
cela c'est unique à travers le monde
cette méthodologie là quand je parle de
chats mes collègues par le monde et
salive parce qu'ils se disent mon dieu
vous avez des moyens que nous n'avons
pas et comme sur d'autres collègues les
parents
vous allez même la personne parfaite
pour faire ça parce que vous dirigez
hydro québec vous connaissez par coeur
énergie que vous avez dirigé durant des
années
ouais bah c'est pas que le match et la
personne parfaite c'est parce que c'est
un parfait parce qu'on a des
actionnaires chez nrj requis sont
largement la caisse des dépôts chez nous
au gouvernement paie quand on se met
ensemble
si c'est ça la logique l'iphone
ambitieux faut être pragmatique qu'il
faut faire c'est un partenariat
j'ai juste gardé un petit peu de temps
parce que je veux parler de l'afrique
des profits quand même cette année de
20% pour les neuf premiers mois en
raison de la coved 19
est ce que c'est un impact qui est
purement momentanée ou il ya des effets
structurels en ce moment sur la demande
vous pensé pour la suite des choses
je pense que les deux monsieur fillion
est évidemment un élément conjoncturel
mais structurel main puis c'est ça qu'on
veut voir avec le temps combien de temps
qu'ont mis ça vaut prendre de temps à
rouvrir notre économie à plein régime
il ya probablement des entreprises qui
vont malheureusement disparaître
on en espère loin possible n'oubliez
avoir une conséquence mais à travers
tout ce qu'on vous fait puis tout ce
qu'on annonce aujourd'hui avoir aussi
des entreprises qui vont être et de tout
seul c'est difficile aujourd'hui ce
serait en fait très présomptueux de dire
quelle va être net net de tout ça nous
font penser que on va rétablir notre
profitabilité au cours des prochaines
années puis encore une fois en vaut le
faire avec détermination mais je
voudrais pas que les gens pensent que on
électrifie l'économie pour craquer la
profitabilité hydro québec ça rien à
voir oui on voit ce pays nous mêmes
cette cette balance commerciale document
écrit équilibré mais d'abord et avant
tout il faut qu'on réussisse notre
transition puis que ça coûte pas trop
cher pour le monde il faut s'occuper à
la fois de ceux qui craignent la fin du
manque de ceux qui craignent la fin du
mois parfait c'est très bien beau
message merci beaucoup madame rochât au
plaisait